So let me say a few things about the idea of this class.
So Hegel has always suffered from the problem
that he is very hard to teach.
And the reason he is very hard to teach
is because there is no book by Hegel
that is the equivalent of the critique of pure reason,
or the ethics of Spinoza, or the Republic of Plato,
or Truth is a Human Nature.
That is to say, a single book that you
could teach either in the course of a semester,
or you could teach a significant chunk of a semester,
that gives you, if not the philosopher's whole system,
at least enough of it that you can kind of figure out
how everything fits into it.
The closest thing in Hegel would be the philosophy of right.
But that is really only a very small part of Hegel's system.
The books by Hegel that do contain a more complete
presentation of the system have this problem
that they are unbelievably hard to read,
in particular this one, the Phenomenology of Spirit.
So the standard way that Hegel gets
taught at the undergraduate class
is you teach the Phenomenology of Spirit.
So in the past when I've taught this class,
I have done the standard thing.
You try to read the Phenomenology of Spirit.
The problem with that is that in one semester,
you can only really do half of the Phenomenology.
I never managed to get to the end.
And the Phenomenology of Spirit is, I think,
the hardest book in the entire Western philosophical tradition.
So what has this experience teaching the Phenomenology
of Spirit that, at a certain point, people aren't really
reading the book anymore.
They're just kind of getting a kind of indirect high level
summary of it.
And they're kind of talking about Hegel,
but they're not really talking about what's in the book.
And that's not just true of students
in undergraduate classes.
On Hegel, I sometimes have the impression
with a lot of so-called Hegel scholars
that they're not really reading the same book that I am.
They're kind of like doing this second hand high level
summary of Hegel.
So the last time I taught 316, I went the opposite direction.
We read the Phenomenology of Spirit line by line.
In fact, in at least one three hour course,
we didn't get past a single sentence.
That had the contrary benefit that people were really, really
reading the text.
However, it had the complementary problem
that we didn't get very far.
And after a certain point, even if you're
reading it sentence by sentence, Hegel
is extraordinarily difficult.
So this class is going to go in the opposite direction.
The idea of this class is that we're going to do,
or I'm going to present, the entirety of Hegel's system,
or at least not the whole thing.
You can't do the whole thing one semester.
I'm going to talk about all of the main structural moments
of Hegel's system.
And I'll talk about this in more detail, a little bit more
detail later today, and much more detail in several weeks.
We're going to talk about the Phenomenology of Spirit, which
is the introduction to the system, which has three parts,
logic, philosophy of spirit.
Sorry, I really should bring my notes with me.
Philosophy of nature, that's an embarrassing mistake.
The philosophy of spirit.
So we're obviously not going to read every part.
The book that presents this whole thing is called the Psychopedia.
We're not going to read the entire Encyclopedia.
That would be ridiculous.
But we're going to talk about all of the main structural moments
of this.
So we're going to spend the first two weeks on the Phenomenology
of Spirit.
We're going to spend three, four, five, six, from weeks three
to six on the logic, which means we're
going to talk about the beginning.
And we're going to talk about the end.
And then we're going to spend a week on the transition
to the philosophy of nature.
Then we're going to spend a week talking
about the move from the philosophy of nature
to the philosophy of spirit.
And then we're going to spend one week on the philosophy of right.
It's week nine.
We're going to spend, I feel like I've missed a week somewhere
in here.
This is not quite accurate.
But you get the basic picture.
And then we're going to spend one week on art, one week on religion,
and then one week on philosophy, which
is the return of the philosophy of spirit back to the logic.
So we're not going to cover every single part of the system.
But we are going to talk about all the major moving parts.
So the other idea that sort of mixed in with this idea for this course
is we're going to read all the parts of Hegel you can just read.
We're going to read all the easy parts of it.
And we're going to read them in systematic order
so that you have some idea of what Hegel's philosophical system actually
is.
The other problem with reading the phenomenology of spirit,
the other problem with treating the phenomenology of spirit
as like the textbook for an undergraduate Hegel course,
is I'll talk about this more later today and more next week.
The phenomenology of spirit is in a certain way,
although this requires qualifications, only Hegel's negative view.
It should bear the subtitle wrong answers only.
So the phenomenology of spirit is a series of failed attempts,
failed accounts of what knowledge is.
So it's just very weird that this book has become treated
as the critique of pure reason of Hegel.
That is just, I mean, Hegel would be totally shocked
that this is the book that everyone reads,
because it's basically his jubinellia.
And he wasn't even really sure what to do with it
once he had completed the mature system, which is this.
OK.
So that's the idea of what you've gotten yourself into.
Some course mechanics.
The syllabus is on Quercus.
I will just say a few things about it.
I find discussing course mechanics in the beginning
of the semester really boring.
So I'm going to do this very quickly.
You have to write two essays, and there is a final exam
during the exam period.
The, you know, it couldn't be more straightforward.
OK.
Your participation grade will be determined
on the basis of how many weeks you submit questions
about the reading.
So the questions about the reading should be written.
You can type them if you want, but it's also
fine to submit them just handwritten,
as long as your handwriting is legible.
And they should be questions about the reading for that week.
And not, you know, like, I was an undergraduate too once.
I know all the tricks, right?
So not like you just turn to a random page in the reading,
and you find Hegel saying, the study of philosophy
is hindered by the conduct of only clever argumentation.
Why does Hegel say the, you know,
that's not what I'm looking for.
You know, put, like, say a little bit more
about why this question is relevant or contextualize it.
Given that Hegel says this, and he says this other thing,
how is this compatible?
Why does Hegel think that this transition is unproblematic?
Why is this argument supposed to be good?
How is this consistent?
Something like that.
Two for every week.
OK.
So some of you probably, how many of you
brought reading questions for this week?
OK, good.
That's great.
A lot of you joined the class later,
didn't know about this, so I'm going
to treat those as extra credit.
You can hand them, you can give them to me
at the end of the day.
But in general, they're due first thing.
So you know, this is like, don't show up
and think you can scribble a few questions about the reading
and grab total credit for it.
That's not going to work.
OK.
Other than that, how many of you here are auditing this class?
That's a lot.
That's like an insane number.
OK.
So let me just say, those of you who
are taking this class for credit,
you have something of great value that other people want,
which means you have to earn it.
So do your best work.
Because if you don't do your best work,
I would prefer that you just drop the class
and one of the people who's auditing it take your spot.
Because many of them are very, very motivated.
OK.
Let me say one or two things more.
Why is Hegel relevant, or why is Hegel important?
Why should you spend the amount of energy
that you're going to have to expend this semester on Hegel?
I mean, the other reason that I've designed this class
is I wanted to finally teach a Hegel class that
wasn't impossibly difficult.
This is supposed to be like moderate level difficulty
Hegel.
OK.
I mean, for the most part, not a sign of a really impossible
hard things in Hegel.
But there's a few weeks where we are
going to read some really hard stuff in Hegel,
and I will kind of hold your hand through those.
OK.
So I regard Hegel as the philosophical equal,
the peer of Plato and Aristotle.
I think he's the only modern philosopher other than Kant,
who has that kind of status.
In a more generous mood, or if Tariq Dicco were here,
I would include Heidegger.
But, and Hegel has had an enormous influence
on European philosophy, the Western philosophy,
after that.
But always, I think, in a distorted form.
That is to say, the Hegel that was taken up
and was influential in philosophy after that
was always in one way or another distorted version of Hegel.
So that, in a certain way, the true Hegel
remains to be understood and really
philosophically appreciated.
Which also makes reading Hegel very exciting,
because there's more work to be done in understanding Hegel,
not just exegetically, but philosophically,
than there is with any other comparably
important modern philosophy, even Kant, especially Kant.
Kant is, in a certain way, relatively well understood,
vastly better understood than Hegel.
And Hegel has only himself to blame for this.
The books are, aside from the philosophy of right,
extraordinarily kind of maddeningly difficult.
Sometimes read as though they are.
So Hegel has a reputation, especially
in the English language tradition,
of just being an author of Gable de Gug of gibberish.
That's not true.
That reflects more on the readers who say that,
or that he's some kind of mystic.
Also, that's just a simple misreading.
But the books are forbiddingly difficult and dense.
There are significant chunks.
I mean, I've spent so much time reading these books.
I'm on my second read.
I read the Phonology of Spirit cover to cover
with some friends, and then I immediately
started rereading it from scratch.
And that's my fourth complete read through in my life.
And I'm constantly rereading the Science of Logic.
There are chunks of these books that I just
have to throw my hands around.
I don't really know what's going on.
Now, there's a reason, and we'll see this
over the course of the semester.
It's not just that Hegel was a bad writer, which he wasn't.
So Hegel has this reputation for being a bad writer.
This is simply false.
When Hegel wants to, he can be eloquent, indeed beautiful.
There's actually a philosophical reason
for why the books are written as densely as they are.
I also think part of the reason why some parts of the books
are as dense as they are is because Hegel had not fully
worked out his theory.
He had not fully worked out his system in all of the detail
that he presents it as having been worked out in.
Failures of presentation are often failures of thought.
And I think to some extent, that's
part of what's going on with Hegel in some places.
And also, I think there are philosophical reasons
for why the books have to be written in this way that
is extremely difficult to read.
But because Hegel has, in my view,
never been received as Hegel, that is to say,
the reception of Hegel has always been the distortion
of Hegel.
That makes Hegel exciting.
In a certain way, in other moods,
I would say this more vociferously.
In a certain way, the big, unaccomplished task
of philosophy in Western tradition
is fully understanding and grappling with Hegel.
I think that's the thing that hasn't really been done.
And this class can serve as a kind of introduction
to doing that, and maybe an inspiration to you
to do that further.
Because one of the ways that I hope this class will function
is as a propagutic for you to read more of Hegel
on your own, an entry point in Hegel
so that you can study it more on your own.
OK, there is no textbook for this class.
All of the readings are going to be online
on corkis in the form of PDFs, which
means that if you want to, you can read them on screens.
And that means that I will have to allow laptops
in this class if normally I don't, which I hate doing.
The reason I hate doing that is because these things are just
distraction machines.
So whenever you see a screen, what you should see
is a conspiracy by very rich and powerful people
to destroy your mind and ruin your life,
because that's, in fact, what they are.
They are the great toxin of our contemporary world.
And so I would prefer to not have them in the classroom.
Somehow, all of the best philosophy ever written
was written without them, so we don't actually
need them for any of this.
In fact, all of the best philosophy
was done and taught without artificial light.
So I would really like to someday teach a class.
If you go to old German universities,
if you go to what is now Pumboldo Investitatie
in Berlin, the University of Berlin,
where Hegel is a professor, the Bruins
have these gigantic floor-to-ceiling windows,
because of course, there was no artificial light.
And teaching by candlelight is not really a safe or
particularly practical.
So in fact, we don't even need this horrible fluorescent
or a headlighting that's ugly and destroys,
diminishes the human spirit.
But unfortunately, we are stuck with this institutional setup.
So that was all a way of saying, I encourage you
to print out the reading and read Hegel in print,
because all of the evidence is that you understand
and remember things better when you read them in print.
When you read something on paper,
you have this multimodal sensory experience of it.
It's both tactile.
If it's a pretty old book, it has an olfactory dimension.
You shouldn't taste the books.
You have a gustatory dimension.
But there's all the physical, it's carrying it around.
You develop a physical relationship with your book.
So if you've ever taken a class under critique of pure reason,
by the end of the semester, your critique is like this.
Binding has been destroyed.
It's covered in notations.
And it's like a physically important object to you.
And that physical defecation to the book, I think,
actually improves your learning and reading experience.
Even better would be if you wanted to buy or somehow
acquire the physical books.
But I'm not going to require that because, of course,
we're only going to read a little bit of this
and then a little bit of the science of logic.
If I made you buy the books for all this class,
it would be more expensive than I can reasonably expect from you.
OK.
So that is everything that I'm going
to say about course mechanics before we
dive into the phenomenology of spirit itself.
Let me just say, normally, so GWF Hegel, born in 1770,
you need 31, normally the principle
in which I operate with respect to historical philosophers
is all that we need to say about them is they were born,
they worked, and they died.
Now, I'm going to slightly violate my own rule
because I'm a big fan of the digression.
And in being a fan of the digression in the lecture,
I have no less eminent of precursor than Hegel himself
because in the transcripts of Hegel's lectures, some
of which we will read, Hegel's constantly
going on these digressions, some of which
are totally off topic and some of which are hilarious.
He'll talk about some recent play that's been displayed.
So a little bit of digression is fun,
distracts us from what Hegel calls the rigor of the concept.
But occasionally, biographical remarks about Hegel
will actually be exegetically relevant.
And so I'll say a few things about Hegel's life.
OK.
This was all that I want to say initially
about Hegel's philosophy.
I don't like beginning a class by giving
this big aerial overview of the philosopher
or the philosophical work precisely because it's
given purely externally.
It's just narration.
It's something you could learn from the Stanford
Encyclopedia of Philosophy or YouTube.
It's not philosophy.
It wouldn't be philosophically justified.
It wouldn't be doing any philosophy for you.
We wouldn't be doing any philosophy together.
I'd just be telling you some stuff.
So as we'll see, because Hegel takes very seriously
the ambition that philosophy should develop everything
from itself, it's particularly inappropriate to Hegel
to begin with this external just telling you something,
mere reports.
I would prefer to begin talking about Hegel
by doing philosophy in the Hegelian way, which
is developing it internally just through thinking something
through.
So that's all that I want to say initially
about Hegel's philosophy.
I'll just say one or two things more
about what's special about Hegel.
Hegel is probably the most ambitious philosopher
who's ever existed.
So the ambition of Hegel's philosophy
is to develop all of this, which is
to say a completely systematic epistemology,
a completely systematic metaphysics,
a completely systematic account of the natural world,
a completely systematic account of the mind, which
includes a completely systematic account
of moral and political philosophy,
a completely systematic account of art and its history,
a completely systematic account of the history of religion,
And true religion, Hegel calls consonant religion,
without any presuppositions.
That's the most ambitious that I think philosophy has ever
gotten.
So Hegel is, in a certain way, the person
who has the most faith or confidence in philosophy
that I can think of.
Everyone since Hegel has been more disillusioned
about philosophy.
Or another way of pointing that point
is Hegel is even more than Kant.
The person, the philosopher, with the most confidence
that reason, just reasoning, can do everything that we want.
That it can be completely satisfactory.
Reason can be completely self-determinate.
Doesn't need anything outside.
Everyone in philosophy, since Hegel,
has been more pessimistic about the possibility
of this complete self-determination
of rational thought.
Questions about that before we dive
into the phenomenology of spirit itself?
No?
Yeah.
Hey.
I'm not sure what that's supposed to be,
but can I ask something about the question?
Sure.
The question is this.
On the set of us, that's like two, three lines.
But you ask us to contextualize it.
That would require us to pull up Hegel.
But that makes it less space, like one line or two.
So by two or three sentence, do you
make two or three sentence of a whole world together?
You're taking, like, we'll figure it out.
Yeah, you're taking a rule of thumb too precisely.
Oh, the other thing I want to say
is if anyone reads German, I would
encourage you to try to read at least some of this in German.
The translations vary a great deal in quality.
And so one of the themes of this semester
that you will probably learn to find really annoying
will be complaining about various Hegel translations.
I haven't been hard about whether to use this
as the textbook for the course.
This is the closest thing to a collection
of all of the relevant texts that we
would read in this class.
The reason I decided against it is the translations
are, in some cases, very strange.
And the selections are, in some cases, I think not ideal.
And so then I thought, OK, then they're
going to have to listen to me complain, not only
about the translations, but also Holgate selections.
That will open order the hell out of them.
So I'll just make my own selections.
Yes?
I don't know if it's too early, but I
want to know how Hegel connects logic to aesthetics and how.
Oh, that's way too early.
Way too early.
We're not even.
We don't even know what logic is yet.
That's just a word on a blackboard.
So using the Cambridge translations.
Using the Cambridge translations insofar as it's possible.
So the Cambridge translations, the Cambridge Hegel
translations, you might think, oh, my god,
they're going to translate everything.
But they have now translated the phenomenology
of spirit, the science of logic, the encyclopedia logic,
the Hegel's writings from Heidelberg, and that's it.
And so you might think, oh, everything's coming out more.
No, Hilary Gaskin, the main philosophy
editor at Cambridge University Press,
has announced it's complete.
That's all they're going to do.
And that's all they ever intended to.
That is not, in fact, a complete story.
In fact, so I'll tell you, at some point
when I feel like we need a break,
I'll give you the complete backstory about how
the Cambridge Hegel translation is so radically incomplete.
And it was, of course, never intended to be in complete
this way.
The short answer is they decided to woefully
underpay the editorial order, who all resigned.
And then at some point, the new editorial board,
some point Cambridge just realized
it wasn't worth the money.
So we're now in this totally ridiculous situation
that there is never going to be, in the foreseeable future,
a good, complete translation of the works
of Hegel in England.
So now, OK, I'll say one other thing.
There are two different, there's basically
two different editions of the works of Hegel in German.
The first one is published by a, is now
published by a press in Germany called Zuk.
Those are, if you ever see, they're
sort of very dark blue paperbacks.
That translation goes back to a translation that was made,
sorry, an edition that was made immediately
after Hegel's death by this group called themselves
the Friends of Hegel.
Now, the problem with that edition
is that it isn't up to contemporary
filmological snuff.
In particular, with respect to Hegel's lectures,
they did this thing that from a contemporary point of view
was totally outrageous.
People, the people who were editing Hegel's lectures,
took all of Hegel's notes and the student transcripts
and then composed one sort of condensed version
of all of this information and then destroyed,
in many cases, the originals so that we can't verify
whether their edition was correct.
So this was for, this was until the 70s, the only edition
of Hegel that there was.
Now, after that, there's the Academy edition,
where people actually sat down and did
the really philologically respectable thing.
I mean, the other thing is, for instance, the Friends of Hegel
edition only contains one edition of the Encyclopedia.
It only contains one edition of the Science of Logic.
That, by contemporary philological standards,
is radically inadequate.
The Academy edition does this much more complete job.
But the weird result of that is almost all
of the translations of Hegel into English that
existed historically are based on this.
And so you would think, well, this
would be a perfect opportunity for Cambridge
to do the English translations from that.
But that's not going to happen because they
underpaid the editorial board.
Also, these editorial board guys,
like they're all tenure professors
drawing massive salaries.
They could just do it for free.
But I wouldn't tell that to their face.
So the other thing that's weird is,
so there are all these people make a big deal about this.
They just think, oh, you can never
talk about Hegel's lectures from the old Friends of Hegel
edition.
You have to only cite the Academy edition.
But the problem is, almost all of the reception of Hegel
through the history of philosophy
from his death in 1831 until whenever this was published
in the 60s or 70s was based on the old edition.
So these poorly edited editions of Hegel's lectures
are the things that are really influential.
So when people talk about Hegel's philosophy of history,
almost everyone who's ever engaged
with Hegel's philosophy of history
was engaging with the poorly edited edition,
including Marx and everyone else.
So I think you can't just ignore this one.
In many cases, the older edition, the not so good edition,
makes the text much more readable and fluent.
And so when we come to read some of Hegel's lectures,
for instance, his lectures on the philosophy of art,
the philosophy of religion, and the history of philosophy,
I will assign some of the translations
from the older editions because they're
just more readable.
And they are the things that everyone's been talking about.
Ever since, so if you hear someone talking about Hegel
and some other book, they're almost certainly
talking about this.
So what value would it be to you?
You're like, oh, well, actually, the Hotho transcript.
You don't care.
I barely care.
OK.
Other questions before we start talking
about the phenomenology of spirit?
Yes.
I've heard that three years ago,
you called it a people person.
That only went through 40 or 50 pages of the phenomenology.
Yeah.
What would be the content-wise difference
between these two persons in terms of yours?
More of you will understand what I'm saying in this course.
Or no, the problem with that course is, so I got through
about, did Siwan tell you that?
Yeah.
OK.
Siwan likes that word.
So let's see.
If I did 50 pages in that class, I got more than that.
I got all the way up to maybe sort of skepticism.
But I kind of rushed through some of skepticism.
So we did maybe like 70 pages.
And the problem with that is you just
learn in a lot of detail the early moves
of the phenomenology of spirit, which doesn't tell you.
That basically taught people 10% of this.
This is 10% of this weird, immature, semi-juvenalia
introduction to Hegel system.
It's not Hegel system.
OK.
But to say more about why just teaching
the phenomenology of spirit would be so inadequate,
I mean, certainly this version of 360
is an elaborate apology for the last time I taught 360.
Let's just dive into the text.
So if you do not have a copy of the text,
rearrange yourself so that you are sitting next to someone
who does have a copy of the text.
So I'll give you a few minutes to do that.
So if two of you are sitting next to each other
and you have copies of the text, yeah, sorry, what?
Yeah, I mean, there'll be some differences.
But you'll basically know what's going on.
Is anyone in a Hegel island isolated
from any other copy of the text?
I would have brought additional copies of the text
if I had thought of that.
Yeah, no screen.
OK.
It is a natural supposition that in philosophy,
before one gets down to dealing with what is that issue,
namely the actual cognition of what in truth is.
So the issue of philosophy is actually
cognizing what in truth is.
Now, there's two words here in German, erkenen and bissen.
Pinker has, in almost all cases, translated erkenen
has to cognize, and bissen has to know.
But he's, now there is a difference between erkenen
and bissen in Hegel.
But erkenen and bissen are both totally ordinary words
in German for knowledge.
So epistemology in German is referred to as erketnesteri,
the theory of erketens.
That's the noun for erketens.
So it would be totally fine to translate both of them
as knowledge.
But Pinker has decided to just mark in English
a distinction in the German.
So it would be totally fine if we read this as saying,
before one gets down to dealing with what is at issue,
namely the actual knowledge, actually knowing what is true.
So now, Hegel uses the difference
between bissen and erkenen to mark some kind of difference.
But it isn't super crucial right now.
So we can also just read cognition here as knowledge.
It is a natural supposition that in philosophy,
before one gets down to dealing with what is at issue,
namely the actual knowledge of what in truth is.
So the business of philosophy is actually
knowing what in truth is.
So not potentially knowing or kind of knowing or having faith,
but knowing and knowing what is true, what is actually true.
It is first necessary to come to an understanding
about knowledge, which is regarded
as the instrument by which one seizes hold of the absolute
or as the means by which one catches sight of it.
So the first word you should stumble over here
is the absolute.
So the absolute is this major topic
and preoccupation of German philosophy from Kant to Hegel.
So in the context in which Hegel is writing this,
roughly Jena in 1807, the absolute
is the thing everyone cares about.
But I want to put the absolute aside for a moment,
because this is kind of provisional.
Over the course of today, you'll understand better
what I mean by this.
Hegel won't, in the introduction to the phenomenology,
yet have an argument that the topic of philosophy
should be the absolute, or that what the topic of knowledge
is is the absolute.
He, over the course of the phenomenology and the logic,
will develop that.
So this is a foreshadowing of something
that you usually have to argue for,
although his audience in 1807 would assume, of course,
what we really wanted to have knowledge of is the absolute.
So what the absolute is, I'm going
to set aside until we see Hegel's view of the absolute.
But if you need a sort of precursor,
you can think of it as God a little bit better.
You can think of it as the unconditioned in Kant.
A little bit better, you can think of it as Spinoza's God.
Even better, you could think of it as Spinoza's God,
where Spinoza's God is understood neither
determinately as a subject or as an object.
And if that sounds very weird, that's fine.
We'll come back to it.
So the important thing about paragraph 73,
the beginning of the introduction,
is Hegel is playing off various tropes in modern philosophy.
So when you read the beginning of the introduction
of phenomenology, you should think of the beginning
of Locke's essay, concerning the understanding,
or the beginning of conscripti capuris.
The characteristic move of modern philosophy
is before we investigate the object,
we have to investigate the cognitive powers
of the subject.
So what Hegel does now is then riff on various tropes
in modern philosophy.
So he's presenting this thing that you would normally assume.
It is a natural supposition.
Although we'll see that in a certain way,
Hegel doesn't share this supposition.
He's distancing himself from this supposition.
So the natural supposition is, before we
go about the business of knowing objects,
we first have to investigate the power of the knowledge
itself.
We have to know what knowledge is.
So he then riffs on various metaphors
that you find in early modern philosophy.
For one, there might be one rather than another form
of cognition that is better suited to achieving
this final end.
So the idea is, well, you have to decide,
is it the senses that give us knowledge of what is?
Or is it the intellect?
Or is it reason if there's a difference
between the intellect and reason?
Is it faith that gives us knowledge of what is?
So those are the kinds of issues that he's gesturing.
If cognition is a faculty of a determinant kind and scope,
then without a more precise determination
of its nature and limits, one ends up grasping clouds of error
rather than the heaven of truth.
So if knowledge is a particular human ability
among other abilities, then there
are things that that ability can be exercised with respect to
and things that it cannot be exercised with respect to.
So we have to get clarity on that before we
try to go about knowing objects.
If cognition is the instrument for seizing hold
of the absolute, then we don't get the absolute
as it is in itself, but we form and change.
So the idea of, if cognition is something like a tool,
then what it gets us is not the object in itself,
but the object introverse that's shaped by the tool.
So once again, these are not things
I think Hegel needs to put a lot of argumentative weight on.
What he's doing is pointing out that these standard moves
in modern epistemology bring with them these kinds of thoughts.
And he's raising this as a way you could begin in philosophy,
but then also distancing himself by them
by pointing out that those kinds of moves in modern philosophy
bring with them very familiar concerns about whether we'll
ever be able to know reality as it is in itself.
Most importantly, in 1807, the thing that's
always in the back of Hegel's mind is Kant and the idea
that Kant's investigation to the powers of human mind
in the critique of pure reason winds up
proving that we don't know reality as it is in itself.
So he's riffing on all these various thoughts
that if you begin by investigating knowledge
itself, you'll always wind up being distanced from the object
as it is in itself.
Likewise, if we think of knowledge as a passive medium,
well, if you really think through the idea of a passive medium,
a medium kind of changes what passes through it.
And so then you can kind of remove.
So the metaphor is, well, if it's a medium changes,
the light passes into glass.
There's an angle of refraction.
So if we know this, maybe we can infer exactly where
the thing came from.
But then all we'll know is the direction
from which the ray came from.
So Hegel is just riffing on standard metaphors
about knowledge in modern philosophy
and very familiar reasons for thinking
that if you think of knowledge that way,
you will wind up with a conclusion
that you don't know reality as it is itself,
you know it only as it appears to you,
or you know it only in relation to the human mind,
et cetera, et cetera.
Yeah.
So how much we have prior knowledge of the world,
and how he gets to the absoluteness?
Is it relative to us, or is it universal?
We're way too early to get there.
We're at super, super preliminary steps here.
So now I'm going to just, because this is not the last time
I'm on 2016 where I only got 370 pages,
I'm not going to go through sentence by sentence.
I'm going to jump through to particular passages
that I think are eliminated.
So then paragraph 74 begins, and he says, well, look,
if this we could just as well, so let me just read this passage.
If the common concern about falling into error
sets up a mistrust of science, which itself,
untroubled by such scruples, simply sets itself to work
and actually cognizes it, it is still
difficult to say why on the contrary,
a mistrust of this mistrust should not be set up,
and why one should not be concerned
that this fear of erring is already the error itself.
So what he's pointing out is the things that
get us into a mistrust or skepticism
about our ability to know are themselves something
that we could be skeptical about.
In particular, we don't have to assume
that knowledge is an instrument or a tool or a passive media
or one ability among others, that those themselves,
those standard assumptions that structure modern epistemology
and that lead to the conclusion that we don't know realities
of itself are themselves something that is questionable.
Skipping a little bit, but above all, this picture
that he's been somewhat satirically riffing on
presupposes that the absolute stands on one side
and that cognition stands on the other or itself
and separated from the absolute, though cognition is
nevertheless something real.
So what he's saying is the assumption here
in all of this stuff, let's just once again, for now,
treat the absolute as the object of knowledge.
The assumption is I'm over here, the object is a distinct being,
and then somehow I have to overcome this distinctness
in order to know.
And the standard early modern thought
is, well, how could I know an object that's distinct for me?
Well, it would have to affect me, have to affect my senses.
And I would have to have some capacity
to be affected sensorily by it.
And then all of these early modern worries
from Locke, Hume, Kant, Descartes, everyone else,
arise, namely, would that allow us to know the object as it is
or only as it affects us?
Would it allow us to know the way the object really is
or only as it appears to our senses?
So he's pointing out that that very standard picture
of knowledge as a particular relation of one being
to another, or let's say, a capacity that one being has
to know another being or other beings,
is itself something we can question.
We're not stuck with that.
OK.
I'm going to skip 73.
So now he says, look, instead of fussing around with answers
to all of this, that is to say, instead of fussing around
with the whole problem space of early modern epistemology,
empiricism, rationalism, sensibility, understanding,
reason, instead of all of that, instead of fussing around
with answers to all of this, it is
possible to reject these outright
as contingent and arbitrary representations
and to regard the affiliated use of words,
such as absolute cognition, and also objective and subjective,
and countless others, whose meaning is assumed
to be generally known as even a kind of deceit.
So one thing we can do is step back and say,
the meaning of subject, object, cognition, absolutely,
they themselves are things that have to be determined.
It's not self-evident what these things mean,
and it's not self-evident that we have to begin philosophy
by assuming a particular meaning of them
or a particular set up for epistemology, namely,
that one, skipping a little bit.
They constitute only an empty appearance
of a knowing, which immediately vanishes
in the face of the science, which comes onto the scene.
OK.
So just a little note about language.
Bissen is to know.
Bissenschaft is science.
But that means just etymologically in German,
there's a very close connection between Bissen and Bissenschaft.
So for now, Hegel has a very distinctive notion
of what a Bissenschaft is.
He hasn't developed it yet.
So let's just take on board the idea
that if the aim of philosophy is to know, to have Bissen,
the aim of philosophy is to be a Bissenschaft,
that is to say, to be a science, a body of knowing.
Now, this is unnatural in English
because we have two different words.
And because we have this, frankly,
stupid tendency in English to assume that the word science
only applies to the natural sciences.
That just doesn't make sense in German.
In German, the study of literature
is the Tsozwe Bissenschaft, the study of politics
is Politische Bissenschaft.
Any systematically ordered body of knowledge is Bissenschaft.
So the introduction of science at this point
is not as arbitrary as it seems, although over the course
of the system, we'll get a much, much richer notion of science.
So all that Hegel is doing is saying, look,
it's standard to begin by assuming
that we want in philosophy is knowledge,
that is to say, scientific knowing, science,
of what actually is.
And the standard way we begin is by assuming this.
But this leads very quickly by arguments
that are familiar from early modern philosophy
to the conclusion that we don't know objects
as they are in themselves.
We only know their appearances or other structural features.
Or even more radically, in Hume, in some way,
we don't really know anything other than our own impressions
of objects.
But we don't have to assume that because it's not obvious
what any of these terms mean.
OK.
But then he says, all of this vanishes
when science comes on the scene.
So when someone who has scientific knowing,
who knows what, in actuality, is the case,
and does so scientifically, when they show up,
all of the rest of this is revealed to be deceit.
But science, insofar as it comes on the scene,
is itself an appearance.
Science is coming onto the scene is not yet science
as it is carried out and unfolded in its truth.
So if I don't have knowledge, I just
have various beliefs involving these concepts.
I'm just a standard early modern epistemology person.
And someone comes on the scene who does have knowing,
that's just one more claim to knowledge among others.
We don't yet know who has knowledge.
Merely, the first appearance of knowing,
the first person who knows, doesn't necessarily
know that they know.
So Hegel goes on to say, for with regard
to a knowing that is not truthful,
science cannot simply reject it as just a common view of things
while giving out the assurance that it is itself
a completely different kind of cognition
and that the other knowing counts as absolutely nothing
for science.
Skip the rest of the sentence, through such an assurance,
science declares its being to be its power.
But untrue knowing, just as much appeals to the fact
that it is, and it gives out the assurance that science counts
as nothing to it, but one bear assurance
is just as valid as another.
So bear assurance is the old translation.
It just sounds better.
It's perfectly fine.
So what does that mean?
What it means is, if you don't know but have mere opinion,
and I come on the scene and I know,
my assertion that I know is worth just as much
as your assertion that you know, even if I know.
So the issue here is how we know what knowledge is,
or how we justify our epistemic standard.
So the issue is not knowledge of objects.
It's knowledge of what knowledge is.
So the idea is, it's not enough simply to know,
because your claim to know is just a mere assertion,
a bear assurance, just as valid and just as invalid
as the person who doesn't actually know their claim to know.
So we need to find somewhere to adjudicate
between the mere claim to knowledge, mere opinion,
and knowledge.
So knowing is agreement?
Argument?
Agreement.
Agreement, no.
OK.
Skipping a bit, 77.
Because this exposition has for its object only
knowing as it appears.
So what we're going to do is we're
going to look at appearances of knowledge.
That is to say, claims to know.
But once again, we're not interested in particular.
I claim to know that Bismarck is the capital of South Dakota.
I claim to know that Fargo is not the capital of South Dakota.
Maybe someone, some poor, benated, Canadian,
ignorant of the geography of the Upper Midwest, my homeland,
might claim to know falsely that Fargo is the capital of South
Dakota.
It is not.
We're not interested in that.
We're interested in the sort of one level more general
about what you think knowledge is.
So the exposition has for its object only knowing as it appears.
That is to say, appearances of conceptions of knowledge.
So you have a conception of what knowledge is.
I have a conception of what knowledge is.
Even if my conception is right, let's just assume yours is right.
My claim about what knowledge is is just as valid as yours.
One is just to bear assurance just as much as the other.
It does not itself seem to be the science, which
is free and self-moving within its own proper shape.
So this exposition does not itself seem to be the science.
So when Hegel says something doesn't appear or merely appears,
that's really important.
So he's saying you would think at the beginning
this exposition is not going to be science
because we don't know what science is yet.
We don't know what knowledge is.
It will actually turn out to be more complicated than that later on.
But let's just take the appearance at face value for now.
So this exposition where there's an appearance of knowing
is just someone's claim to knowing backed up
by some conception of knowledge.
That doesn't look to be knowing yet because they
don't know that they know.
But from this standpoint can instead
be taken to be the path of natural consciousness,
pressing forward towards true knowing.
It can be taken to be the path of the soul wandering
through this series of ways it takes shape,
as if these were stations put forward in advance to it
by its own nature so that it purifies itself into spirit
by arriving at a cognition of what it is in itself
through the complete experience of its own self.
So that description, 77 is a description of this book.
It's an exposition, which appears not to be science
itself yet, and let's stick with the appearance.
Let's assume that this is from the first page not yet science,
but merely the appearance of science.
But what it really is is it's the path of natural consciousness.
So what is natural consciousness?
It's something like the conception of knowledge
we begin with pre-philosophically.
Very roughly, it's this.
It's the idea that there's a distinction
between consciousness, the subject,
and its other, the object, and that consciousness
has to somehow overcome that, maybe
by the object affecting its senses, et cetera, et cetera.
This is natural consciousness.
So the exposition, this book is going
to be an exposition of the path of natural consciousness
pressing forwards towards true known, towards science.
Or it can be taken to be the path of the soul wandering
through the series of ways it takes shape.
So the phenomenology of this will
be an exposition of different shapes or forms
of consciousness, which means different conceptions
of what knowledge is, different conceptions
of the relationship between consciousness and its object.
As if these were stations put forward in advance to it
by its own nature.
So these stations, these different forms of consciousness,
are not given to it from outside,
but they develop out of it itself,
so that it purifies itself into spirit
by arriving at a cognition of what it is in itself
through the complete experience of its own self.
So this is going to be the exposition
of how natural consciousness becomes spirit,
and therefore truly knows itself and has scientific knowledge.
Now, what is this exposition?
What is the character of the exposition of the phenomenology?
So one very standard way of reading the phenomenology
that I think is totally wrong is to think of it
as an historical description of various shapes of human
consciousness over time.
So on this reading, some of the beginning of the book
is like Stone Age consciousness, and by the end
we have like early 19th century German consciousness.
This has various problems, one of which
is it gets the chronology as out of order.
So somehow like Newtonian science comes before the Greeks.
There are other problems with it, namely,
it makes the whole book completely incoherent.
It turns it into the world's most incoherently written
piece of intellectual history.
It's like Will Durant, as written by Hegel.
And it also completely undermines
the philosophical account, because what happened does not
in and of itself have any necessity.
So I don't think that it's historical.
I think that this exposition is a purely
philosophical or logical.
So what we do is we start with natural consciousness, which
is a conception of what knowing is.
It's roughly this.
As we'll see, it's going to start even more minimally
than this.
We're going to start with this, and then we're
going to develop out of this other shapes of consciousness,
other conceptions of what knowledge is,
till we get to what Hegel identifies as science, what
he identifies as the knowing of the absolute,
and what he here identifies as consciousness becoming spirit.
Now, all of those things are going to be the same.
They're all going to be identical.
But let me just say something about the latter.
What does it mean that consciousness becomes spirit?
As Hegel says at the end of 77, it's
not that consciousness wasn't spirit and then becomes spirit.
It's that consciousness becomes aware of itself as spirit.
So one way of thinking about the phenomenology, the one
that I'm going to emphasize, is its consciousness developing
out of itself a series of shapes of consciousness,
conceptions of knowing, until it gets to one
that is knowing, full stop.
True scientific knowing of what in actuality is.
That will turn out also to be knowledge of the absolute.
For the preview of incredibly weird Hegel stuff to come,
it will turn out that that is the absolute.
The absolute is the absolute knowing itself.
And you can be part of it too.
But the thing I just want to mention now
is it will also be consciousness coming
to know what it itself is, namely, spirit.
Now we're going to talk a lot more about spirit in this class
because it's one of the three parts of the system.
And we'll spend roughly half this whole semester on spirit.
What exactly spirit is in Hegel is if you gave me a pop quiz
and gave me a blue book and said you have three hours to say
what spirit is for Hegel, I think
I would throw myself out of a window.
I don't really know how I would do that.
But let me just say very briefly something about the word.
The word in German is geist.
OK.
Now, sometimes that gets translated in English
as spirit, sometimes it gets translated as mind.
So in particular, the translation
of the philosophy of spirit that we're
going to read, the only one ever published in English
because Cambridge underpaid the editorial board,
translated as the philosophy of mind.
Now, what is the relationship between spirit and mind?
They're the same word in German.
If you want to say that someone lost his mind in German,
you say, he hasein geistfel.
So we have two words where the Germans have won.
Now, Hegel is exploiting a feature of German, which
is that the word that you would use for my individual mind,
is also the word that you would use
for collective mental phenomena, like the spirit of the age.
If you say in English, the mind of the 19th century,
people will be like, what?
What's that like?
That sounds like the board.
Everyone in the 19th century was hooked up
into some big telepathic worldwide web.
Now, if you say zeitgeist, the spirit of the age in German,
that sounds totally normal.
So what Hegel is playing on the fact
that there's one word for individual mental phenomena
and collective mental phenomena.
Because what he wants us to see is
that those aren't really separate things.
Not that there's only one mind and we're all parts of it,
or that the collective mind is just the combination
of the little minds, as Margaret Thatcher famously said,
there's no such thing as society.
But neither of those views.
As always in Hegel, a third weirder thing.
But just very briefly, what matters
in the phenomenology of spirit is
that over the course of the phenomenology,
consciousness comes to realize that it's spirit.
Consciousness comes to realize that it's a mind.
No, no, no.
He means spirit in a more technical sense.
Consciousness will come to realize
that there is no difference between it and its author.
Spirit is mind in so far as it understands
that it has no other.
Now that is not going to mean that everything is spirit.
So Hegel's view is not like this is spirit.
Hegel's fully aware that there is no spirit on the moon.
The view that the phenomenology is building up towards
is that the other of spirit, nature, things that have reality
but aren't minds, are not fundamentally
different from spirit.
So that although spirit has another,
its other isn't fundamentally other to it.
Or it's the same structurally as spirit.
Now this is all provisional.
All of this is going to be worked out
in the rest of the system.
But the basic idea is that spirit is consciousness
raised to the point where it understands
that the basic structure in which consciousness thinks
is the same structure as what it thinks about.
So although there's a difference between myself and the object,
it's not an ultimate difference.
The way I think about things is fundamentally the way they are.
And what's important for Hegel is
that we're going to prove that.
We're not going to presuppose it.
Hegel's way of thinking about this, preconti and rationalism
just presupposes that the categories of thought,
basically subject, predicate, and logic,
are the metaphysical structure of being.
Or they assume something even worse,
which is that God just decided, because he's
nice, to set things up that way.
Because what God really cares about
is that we do metaphysics properly.
The murder of innocence and the complete slaughter field
that is history was relatively different to him.
He was figuring out how to create the world.
But he was like, wait, if I do it this way,
there's going to be all these genocides and all this slavery
and all this horrible shit.
But they'll be able to do metaphysics.
Yes, I'll do that.
So Hegel thinks that's even worse.
So what we need to do over the course of the system
is show that consciousness has to be spirit.
That is to say, there can't be a fundamental difference
between the categories in which thought thinks and the beings
that it thinks about.
And so that's going to mean that there's
a structural identity between spirit and nature.
Yes?
The individual mental phenomena,
collective mental phenomena, are key names
or is it too much experience?
You're getting ahead of us.
We're not there yet.
Yeah, Isaac, right.
Yeah.
So is there any comparable traits
between the non-monetary atmosphere
and the non-monology of this technology in 20th century?
Is there any connection at all?
I will answer that question when we
get to a particular passage.
Notice the word phenomenology has not been used yet.
Maybe a bit naive, but why start with natural consciousness?
We will get there.
Yeah?
What is the concept of what is the notion?
Oh, it's the bad old English translation of the concept.
To the next question, what is the concept?
That's, we will, it's going to take us a couple weeks.
But it doesn't use it here.
He uses it here, but he uses it in a non-technical sense
here to mean something like one's conception.
OK.
Yeah.
I know you said consciousness realizes that it's spirit.
Maybe it's a silly question, but what's the difference
before we know, before I as a consciousness realize
that I am spirit?
What is the difference between spirit and consciousness?
It's the difference between being something
and being aware of yourself as being that.
So your spirit all along.
Where consciousness is always spirit,
but it doesn't grasp itself as spirit.
Or I mean, once again, it's important not
to think of this temporally.
This is not about a guy named consciousness
who realizes at the end that he's spirit.
It's about consciousness.
And consciousness is spirit, but at the level
at which we describe consciousness at the beginning,
that is not a description of consciousness as spirit.
What we're going to do is unfold from that description
of consciousness, just from what consciousness is so
described that it must be spirit.
OK.
Moving on.
Natural consciousness will prove
to be only the concept of knowing,
or it will prove to be not real knowing.
OK, good.
So this is a non-technical use of concept.
This is something like what we mean
by concept in the ordinary sense.
It's a conception of knowing.
So natural consciousness thinks of itself as knowing,
and it has a conception of knowing, namely this one.
But it will prove to be not real knowing.
He also said already for that.
While it immediately regards itself rather as real knowing,
this path has negative meaning for it.
And what is the realization of the concept
will count instead to it as the loss of itself,
for on this path, it loses its truth.
In this exposition, consciousness
is going to realize that what it thinks knowing is is not
knowing.
So the truth that it thinks it knows, it doesn't know.
This path could accordingly be regarded
as the path of doubt, or more properly,
as the path of despair.
On this path, what happens is not
what is customarily understood as doubt,
a shaking of this or that supposed truth,
followed by the disappearance again of the doubt,
and then a return to the former, so that in the end,
the thing at issue is taken as it was before.
Rather, this path is the conscious insight
into the untruth of knowing as it appears.
A knowing for which that which is the most real
is rather in truth only the unrealized concept.
So what that means is consciousness
is going to realize, not that it's wrong about it
thought it knew something, but it didn't know that thing.
It thought it knew that Fargo is the capital of North Dakota,
but it isn't.
Or it's nor is it going to doubt, it's
going to say, well, there's a bunch of stuff I don't know.
I don't know anything about how things are in themselves.
I didn't know the external world.
What it's going to doubt is its conception of knowledge.
And that is the loss of itself, because a conception
of knowledge is a conception by consciousness
of what consciousness is.
So in losing that, it loses itself.
So there's this kind of existential dimension.
These are losses of self-conceptions.
So the phenomenology is also an exposition
of a sequence of self-conceptions
that consciousness might have of itself.
I'm going to skip a bunch.
So we know where we start, natural consciousness.
Although we don't really know what natural consciousness is,
this is my preliminary sketch of it.
He hasn't really told us what natural consciousness is.
We know roughly where things are going to end.
They're going to end with scientific knowledge,
where whatever doubt is generated
about these models of knowledge,
that will not be able to be generated anymore.
We don't really know why.
The completeness of the forms of non-real consciousness
will emerge through the very necessity
of their progression and their interrelations.
The progression of one form of consciousness,
one conception of knowledge to another,
is going to be necessary, not contingent.
To make this comprehensible, it can
be noted in general at the outset
that the exposition of non-truthful consciousness
in its untruth is not merely a negative movement.
So Hegel now needs to explain why we transition
from one shape of consciousness to the next.
Now, rereading the introduction today,
I think this is, I came to the conclusion
this text is not actually in the best order
that it could be in, because only a little bit later
will he explain exactly how consciousness
undermines a shape of consciousness.
But let's set that aside.
Let's assume there's some notion of consciousness
realizing that its conception of knowledge is wrong.
Now we need to understand how it moves to the next one.
Now, I just want to emphasize one thing,
that this is a process, or this development,
is not about particular knowledge claims.
We're not interested in particular knowledge
claims about particular objects.
It's at the level of a whole epistemology,
a whole conception of what knowledge is.
That's what's getting under it.
That's why doubt about that is the loss
of consciousness itself.
If you find out that you thought you knew
that South Dakota was the capital of,
sorry, that Fargo was the capital of South Dakota,
and then you find out you're wrong,
you don't lose yourself in that,
unless you have way more invested
in the geography of the Upper Midwest than you should.
Assuming that we're counting as the Dakotas
as part of the Midwest, which, okay,
we can debate about that.
You guys are probably not as invested
in inter-Midwest rivalry as I am.
But that's how we learn from each other.
Okay, so it's not merely a negative movement.
So when consciousness realizes
that its conception of knowledge is false,
that isn't, it doesn't merely reject it.
It's not just like not that.
However, only when taken as the nothing
of that from which it is, from which it emerges,
is the nothing, in fact, the true result.
Thus, it is itself a determinate nothing,
and it has a content.
So when consciousness undermines
some shape of consciousness, some conception of knowledge,
the result is not just pure,
just the abandonment of knowing.
Not just pure nothing.
It's a specific or determinate negative nothing.
It's the rejection of that previous shape,
which is itself its own shape.
So what Hegel needs to do is give us a principled reason
or a function for why one shape of consciousness
undermines itself and gives rise to the next.
So there has to be, so to speak, a law of the series.
So we have an account of where we start,
we have a kind of preliminary account
of where we're gonna end,
but we also have an account of why we move
to the next one that we do move to.
By contrast, while the result is graphed,
as it is in its truth, as determinate negation,
a new form has thereby immediately arisen.
And in the negation, the transition is made
whereby the progression through the complete series
of shapes comes about on its own accord.
So to say that a shape of consciousness
is a determinate negation is to say that it isn't something,
but it's not nothing in general.
It's not just nothing.
There's a specific thing it isn't,
namely the previous shape of consciousness.
In particular, it's a shape of consciousness
that arises in a principled way out of the failure
of the previous shape of consciousness.
And Hegel is now going to give us an account
of exactly what that function is
that gets you from one shape of consciousness
that fails to the next.
But again, rather than doing that,
he then skips to the next topic, which is where it ends.
So what we need is an account of where we start,
how we move, and where we end.
We've seen a little about where we start,
a little about how we move,
and now Hegel's gonna tell us more about how we end.
However, to knowing the goal is necessarily fixed
as the series of the progression
is as necessarily fixed as the series of the progression,
although you haven't really told us exactly
what the series of the progression is, Hegel.
The goal is the point.
The goal is the point at which knowing
no longer needs to go beyond its own self.
Where knowing itself finds itself,
and where the concept corresponds to the object,
and the object to the concept.
The progression towards this goal
is thus also unrelenting,
and at no earlier stage dissatisfaction to be felt.
So this process will end
when there's so little distinction
between subject and object,
between knowing and the object of knowing,
that no skepticism about that shape of consciousness
is possible.
So it's going to end only with such a complete coincidence
of knowing at its object
that the skeptical problem
about these conceptions of knowledge cannot arise.
Now what exactly that is,
is only described at the end of the book.
It's very, very hard to understand.
But that's where we're supposed to go.
Okay, now why can consciousness not stop
anywhere short of the entity?
Consciousness therefore suffers this violence
at its own hands,
and brings to ruin its own restricted satisfaction.
So the failure of these forms of consciousness,
these shapes of consciousness,
these conceptions of knowledge,
is not something external.
Consciousness itself realizes
that its conception of knowledge is wrong.
It does it to itself.
With the feeling of this violence,
anxiety over the truth might well withdraw
and strive to hold onto what it is in danger of losing.
But this anxiety can find no rest.
Even if it wants to remain in thoughtless indolence,
thought spoils the thoughtlessness,
and its unrest disturbs the indolence.
So as Hegel says on the next page,
where can I never find this?
I know I have this underlined.
Okay, as he says in the next couple of pages,
which we will come to,
it is an issue for consciousness
whether or not its knowing of the object
corresponds to the object, that's 56.
So consciousness, it cannot be indifferent
to consciousness whether it knows.
So consciousness purports to no objects.
It has a conception of what knowledge is.
And Hegel says it is not indifferent to consciousness.
Consciousness can't just not care
about whether what it thinks knowing is, is knowing.
Now, you might think, well,
knowledge is just one thing in life.
Like I have a lot of family members
who don't care that much about what knowledge is.
They do, only philosophers are so,
only a philosopher could say consciousness
with feeling of this violence,
anxiety over the truth might well withdraw
and strive to hold on to what is in danger of losing.
This anxiety can find no rest.
Even if it wants to remain in thoughtless indolence,
thought spoils the thoughtlessness
that its unrest disturbs the indolence.
A lot of people, their anxiety does find a rest.
They don't, they wanna remain in thoughtless indolence
and thought doesn't spoil their thoughtlessness
and unrest does not disturb their indolence.
They're very happy to not think or not know.
So this is not supposed to be a psychological claim
about particular conscious subjects.
So whatever Hegel's claim is here,
is not supposed to be contrary to
and therefore not refutable to psychological claims
about particular human beings.
As we'll see over the course of the phenomenology
or if we were to read the whole phenomenology
as we would see, knowledge,
Hegel thinks of as a very, very general phenomenon.
It's sort of ubiquitous or structural
in human life.
So doing something, action is also a kind of knowledge.
It's a representation of the object
as being in conformity with your representation of it,
as being choice worthy.
So there's no way of being indifferent to knowledge.
Any acting, any willing, any belief about the world
is making a claim to knowledge.
So notice I haven't said that knowledge here
is this thing that analytic philosophers
are kind of pointlessly obsessed with.
S knows that P.
This is a much more general structure.
This is the structure of your relationship with the world.
This you might not care about.
You probably shouldn't care about it.
Stop caring about it.
This you walk around life
carrying with you a conception of this.
It cannot be indifferent to you
whether the world does actually relate to you
the way you conceive it as related to you.
Okay, a little bit further and then we'll take a break.
Just as these preliminary and general remarks
about the manner and the necessity of the progression
have been made, so too it might be useful to recall something
about the method of the way it is carried out.
So Hegel is now gonna tell us more about
how consciousness undermines
its own conception of knowledge or the law of the series.
Sorry, not the law of the series.
The law of the series is how we go from
shape of consciousness and the shape of consciousness
and plus one, but why we have to move on.
Why one shape of consciousness fails.
Just as these preliminary and general remarks
about the manner and the necessity
of the progression have been made,
so too it might be useful to recall something
about the method of the way it is carried out.
This exposition represented as the conduct of science
in relation to knowing as it appears
and represented as the investigation and testing
of the reality of cognition seems incapable
of taking place without some kind of presupposition
with underlies it as a stem.
So it looks like, once again, it appears.
That means he's suggesting this is something you might think
he's ultimately gonna undermine it.
You might think that what we need to do
is have a standard of what knowing is
and then investigate each shape of consciousness
and say, that doesn't meet the standard.
That's not what knowing is.
For the testing consists in the application
of an accepted standard and in the resulting equality
or inequality between the standard and what is tested
lays the decision as to what is tested
is correct or incorrect.
The standard, likewise, science itself,
if science were to be the standard,
is thereby accepted as the essence or as the in itself.
Ignore, we'll come back to essence and in itself.
But here, at the point where science
first comes on the scene,
where someone makes a claim to scientific knowledge,
neither science itself nor anything else
has justified itself as the essence or as the in itself.
And without something like that taking place,
it seems that no examination could take place at all.
So there's this problem.
It looks like we need to apply a standard.
Where does the standard come from?
One can have a more determinant grasp of this contradiction
and the removal of the contradiction.
If, first of all, one is reminded
of the abstract determinations of knowing and truth
as they come before consciousness.
Okay, so what Hegel is doing in 81
is he's making a reference
to something called the dilemma of the criterion.
I'm going to erase Hegel's system.
It's actually very Hegelian.
When we get into Hegel's logic,
there's going to be a lot of erasure.
That's going to be like a main metaphor.
Hegel's a great philosopher to teach on the blackboard.
Okay.
The dilemma of the criterion
comes from a work of ancient philosophy
by Sextus empiricus.
Called outlines of purism.
Here's the basic idea.
Or this is how Hegel is thinking of the idea in Sextus.
That's what matters for our purposes.
Someone makes a claim to knowledge.
We have to have a standard
for whether that counts as knowledge or not.
Whether that's a valid knowledge group.
Whether that person in fact knows what they claim to know.
Now either that standard
is that person's own conception of knowledge.
In which case it's circular.
Very easy.
Now, totally useless.
Everyone's conception of knowledge agrees with itself,
so everyone meets their own standard.
Or the standard has to be external
to their conception of knowledge.
But then it's question-making.
So, what Hegel is doing
is raising this as a problem for his own project.
What we don't want to do
is apply external standards or criterions.
Criteria.
We'll also call it the dilemma of the standard.
Maschab.
So, what he's going to do is develop a way
of how consciousness can undermine
its own conception of knowledge
that doesn't run into the dilemma of the criteria.
One can have a more determinate grasp of this contradiction
and the removal of the contradiction
if first of all, one is reminded
of the abstract determinations of knowing their truth
as they come before consciousness.
Okay, abstract determinations means
these are sort of,
Hegel's now going to give us a very abstract model
of what consciousness acknowledges.
Now, if we were reading the whole phenomenology,
one question would be whether this model
in the introduction actually applies to the whole book.
I don't think it does,
but I think it's fine for our purposes
because it applies to the parts of the book
that we're going to read.
So, consciousness distinguishes something from itself
while at the same time it relates itself to it.
Okay, so I'm going to remove the term subject and object
because those are not yet Hegel's terms.
So we have consciousness.
It has a relation to something distinct from itself
and it also distinguishes itself from it.
Or, as it is expressed,
the something is something for consciousness.
This is for consciousness.
Something consciousness is of.
This something is something for consciousness
and the determinate aspect of this relating
or of the being of something for a consciousness is known.
So knowing is a relation of consciousness to the object.
In this direction, this object is for consciousness.
In this direction, consciousness knows this object.
However, we distinguish the being for another
from being in itself.
That which is related to knowing
is just as much distinguished from knowing
and is positive as being also external to this relation.
The aspect of this in itself is called truth.
So the aspect of being in itself
that it can be if outstanding in this relationship is truth.
Now what does that mean?
What it means is this is a super abstract structural
description of consciousness and knowledge.
Consciousness distinguishes itself from something,
the object of consciousness,
but also relates itself to knowing.
And remember, knowing here
is not necessarily propositional knowledge.
Don't worry about that.
It could be acquaintance, perceiving something.
That's a kind of note, willing something.
But what it knows has some kind of independence
of its relationship to it.
That is to say that being,
what it knows is not identical to its knowledge.
Now that doesn't mean
that this thing is completely independent of this.
It means that it isn't simply identical to this.
It means that if we got rid of this entirely,
we would have a completely different model.
Okay, that's all Hegel is assuming.
Now, Rota's truth here does not mean P.
analytic philosophy is very into P's and Q's and R's.
It is, as I like to call it, philosophy in the key of P.
Hegel is not a philosopher in the key of P.
As we'll see over the course of this semester,
I think it's actually super crucial to understanding Hegel
that Hegel cannot be put in the form of P.
There is no P, there's no value of P,
especially Hegel's view is P.
Yes.
Knowing determines consciousness
or consciousness determines knowing.
Consciousness, for now we're assuming
that knowing is the relationship
of consciousness to the object.
Knowing is a relation that consciousness has to the object.
We only call something consciousness right now
insofar as it stands in a knowing relation
to the object, to the in itself.
Okay, skip a paragraph, but the nature of the object
which we are investigating goes beyond this division
or to this semblance of division and presupposition.
So it looks like we have a distinction
between consciousness and our conception of consciousness.
This thing on the blackboard is a conception of consciousness.
But the nature of this object is that distinction
between this and the whole thing is overcome.
Consciousness in its own self provides its own standard
and the investigation will therefore be a comparison
of itself, of it with itself, for the difference
which has just been made falls within consciousness.
That is to say, consciousness itself
has a conception of this.
So this difference between consciousness
and being in itself falls within consciousness
because consciousness is consciousness.
We can also know if I was a better drawer,
I could have put this thought bubble inside consciousness.
Hard to draw with chalk.
Consciousness is its own self, provides its own standard.
So consciousness brings with it a standard
of what knowledge is.
Therefore, skipping again a few sentences,
therefore in what consciousness declares within itself
to be the in itself or the true, we have the standard
which consciousness itself sets up to measure its known.
So consciousness has a standard, it has to know this.
That sets a standard.
If we designate knowing as the concept,
but designate the essence or the true over here
as what is or the object, then the examining consists
in whether the concept corresponds to the object.
Does this correspond to that?
Is this a way of knowingly relating to that?
Well remember, what relation knowing is also,
it's up to consciousness to say.
So don't assume that it's true justified belief
or whatever.
Let me just go a little bit further.
Oh, 84.
End of 84.
What is essential throughout the whole investigation
is to hold fast to this, that both of these moments,
concept and object, being for another,
being for consciousness and being in itself,
themselves fall within the knowing that we are investigating.
They fall within consciousness.
They fall within consciousness's conception
of itself as known.
And that we thus do not need to bring standards with us
and in the investigation to apply our ideas and thoughts.
But now you might think, okay,
isn't Hegel running into one horn
of the dilemma of the criterion?
Every conception of knowing is just going to agree
with its own standard.
No, Hegel's about target.
That actually shapes of consciousness in general
do not agree with their own standard.
However, from this aspect,
not only will it be superfluous for us to add anything,
and not only because concept and object,
the standard and what is to be examined
are present in consciousness itself,
the only thing that remains is for us to purely look on.
So now this is a super important aspect
of the way Hegel does philosophy.
And this is the first instance of it
that we've seen in the phenomenology.
Hegel's philosophy is supposed to always be imminent.
That means there's some subject matter
and the further development of the claims
about that subject matter in Hegel's philosophy
arise from the subject matter itself.
That means at no point in the phenomenology
can Hegel say, look, it's plausible that this,
or I think that, or in my view this,
everything has to come out of consciousness itself.
And since the beginning of the phenomenology
is natural consciousness,
it has to arise from natural consciousness itself.
So what we do in the phenomenology
is we just observe natural consciousness
developing itself through these shapes of consciousness
to absolute knowing.
It is consciousness of what to it is the true.
So it's consciousness of this
as well as consciousness of its knowing of the truth.
So it's conscious not only of this,
but of this whole thing.
So it's object consciousness,
but also consciousness of itself as knowing
under a particular description of what knowing is.
It is an issue for that consciousness
whether or not it's knowing of the object
corresponds to the object.
So consciousness cannot be indifferent
to whether this agrees with that.
Because it itself has supplied the criteria.
Okay, so we're gonna somehow argue
that various shapes of consciousness
fail their own criteria.
That they think this is a knowing of that,
but this as they themselves conceive it
is not a knowing of that.
Okay, we'll take one a little bit
and then we'll take a break
and then we'll read the last three paragraphs
really carefully.
This dialectical movement.
Ah, okay, so you've been wondering,
you're taking a Hegel class
and he's been doing it for two hours.
He hasn't said the word dialectic yet.
Okay.
Dialectic.
Hegel.
In some sense, all of Hegel's philosophy
works by something called the dialectic
or dialectical progression.
I think the structure of the dialectic
in phenomenology is different
than the structure of the dialectic in the larger.
I don't understand the dialectic
of the philosophy of nature
or really the philosophy of spirit either,
but I really don't understand
the dialectic philosophy of nature.
No one really understands the dialectic philosophy of nature.
But what does Hegel mean by the word dialectic?
There's two historical sources that are relevant.
One, in ancient philosophy,
dialectic, very simply put,
is the science of refuting what other people say.
So it's a negative logical art
where you say something
and I reduce you to absurdity.
In Kant, there's something called the transcendental dialect.
Now the transcendental dialectic actually has three parts,
but Hegel always associates the dialectic with the antinomies.
The idea of the antinomies of pure reason
in the first critique is that reason itself
is subject to a dialectic.
So it's not that someone comes along and refutes reason,
reason refutes itself.
It refutes itself and so far as it assumes
that objects in space and time are things in themselves
because it forms this conception
of something called the unconditioned.
So you take something, you take its conditions
and then you take the complete sequence of its conditions.
And it has a proof that that sequence of conditions
terminates in an unconditioned first condition
and it has a proof that it cannot terminate,
that it goes on infinitely.
That's a contradiction.
And so the resolution to that contradiction, Kant thinks,
is to recognize that objects in space and time
are appearances and so there is no such thing
as the unconditioned totality of their conditions.
If you haven't taken 3.14,
that wouldn't really make a lot of sense to you,
but you should all just take 3.14.
Okay, who's taking 3.14?
Good, the rest of you should model yourselves
on those who are taking 3.14.
So what Hegel means by a dialectic
is as in ancient philosophy,
refutation is a negative, it's negative.
But as with Kant, it's not refutation by some other person.
It's not external refutation, it's self-refutation.
It's the self-refutation here in the phenomenology
of shapes of consciousness,
of conceptions of what knowledge is.
The difference between both ancient dialectic,
Kantian dialectic and Hegelian dialectic
is as we saw earlier, Hegel thinks that dialectic
is not purely negative.
It's productive or positive.
So when we dialectically undermine
the shape of consciousness,
we don't go, oh fuck, we have a contradiction.
That generates positive content.
What Hegel calls the determinant negation
of the refuted shape of consciousness,
which is the successor shape of consciousness,
which in a principled fashion, non-orbitarily,
attempts to resolve the contradiction
in the earlier shape of consciousness.
So no, that's why.
So that means the phenomenology of spirit
is the inner dialectic of knowing.
But it's not just refutation, it's also position.
It's also positive.
The self-refutation of one shape of consciousness
generates the next shape of consciousness.
And that's why it's important
that Hegel give us a principled function
from shape of consciousness n
to shape of consciousness n plus one.
Because otherwise, the imminence
of the phenomenology of spirit would be wrecked.
That is to say, we would have to supply it.
We'd be like, what's a reasonable
next shape of consciousness?
Well, this seems good.
And it would no longer be consciousness developing itself.
And so in a certain way, it would fall a foul
of the problem of the criterion.
Something external to consciousness
would be telling it what its next standard should be.
And consciousness would not be rationally obliged
to accept that.
So we require an in-principle account
of how one shape of consciousness
gives rise to the next shape of consciousness.
Okay, why don't we take a 10-minute break
and come back at 54 past?
If you are auditing this class
and you have not yet been added to Quirkus,
please come speak to me
and I will add you to Quirkus right now.
Hello.
Can I add it?
Yes, you just.
It makes me so warm.
Dial in.